the seattle city council passed an
ordinance this past monday that would
mean a dollar fines for people who put
too many table scraps in their garbage
uh we've got some more info for you
under the new rules collectors can take
a cursory look each time they dump trash
into a garbage truck if they see
composable items make up 10 or more of
the trash they'll enter the violation
into a computer system their trucks
already carry and will leave a ticket on
the garbage bin that says to expect a
dollar fine on the next garbage bill all
right this seems pretty good we're doing
we're throwing away a lot of food we've
talked a lot about food and the
environment on this episode this seems
this seems pretty solid to me i know a
certain amount of people are going to
say the government's now getting in your
garbage and seeing what you're eating
i think you both are going to agree with
me on this it's okay right it's a dollar
and we should try to do a little bit
better look i think it's okay if that's
all it is but personally i have a
problem with somebody digging through my
trash and trying to figure out what's in
there and that that's where my concern
comes in but i am very much concerned
about the environment as well and i do
think we need to
not be throwing away so much food this
is one way to do it here we're
essentially you know slapping people on
the risk for doing it but or penalizing
them but we could also look to other
solutions like there are apps for
example that allow you to share your
leftovers with neighbors or you can
donate extra food like there are other
things we can do and besides throwing it
away or putting in a compost pile well i
think the idea here is that we should be
composting and we shouldn't be putting
it in the trash and you know what
garbage collectors can look through your
trash now i don't think that's against
the law so i that that doesn't worry me
at all a dollar fine sounds like it
wouldn't even have an effect but it
actually i bet you it will and i think
the reason that it can be a deterrent is
the same reason that when you look in
los angeles
where we passed a plastic bag ban if you
notice when you go to the store they
charge now 10 cents for a bag it used to
be free to have a plastic bag now there
are no plastic bags and it's 10 cents
for a paperback and i can't tell you how
many crazy people will be in the
checkout line at target and they'll be
like do you want to spend 10 cents on a
bag and they're like no i'll just carry
it all like it's just insane
10 cents but it actually is a deterrent
so i think that we'll be surprised by
how much of an effect this could
actually have you know so obviously
we're in la here when i go to trader
joe's now i do bring my own bag and i
and i do feel good after like i did
something but i was in new york last
week and i couldn't believe how many
plastic bags like so i did realize that
even though i joke about it like we're
really doing anything
we are doing here governor jerry brown
just signed up a statewide law for
plastic bags so that's kind of cool yeah
that's great um so i want to talk about
composting for a second so we did so
much in this country with uh recycling
like we made it so obvious that you
separate your glass and your your metal
and stuff like that why haven't we done
more with composting because there's so
much goodness that can come out of it
and we've done nothing i can tell you
from experience because i started a
compost pile back when i was 16 and i
was like i took ap environmental science
and i was like oh my gosh i need to do
something for the environment so i did a
bunch of things one of them was start a
compost pile it's hard to do ish like it
smells a lot of like bugs you have to do
it right and i think that's why we don't
do it and people are so concerned about
aesthetics i want my garden to look this
way you know and less concerned about
the longevity of our planet that they'd
rather not do it and i think that's why
recycling is easier you put it in a bin
you don't see it you can feel good about
yourself but you don't have to do much
this requires a little bit more work
science ladies if you live in an
apartment that's tough but there are new
products on the market unfortunately
they're still expensive hopefully
they'll get cheaper where you can do
countertop composting almost like you
know the diaper genie if you know any
friends who have kids they have those
things and they can put the diapers in
their house and you can't smell it they
have countertop composters where you put
the food in it and it seals off the
smell and so you can compass compost
within your house it's a great option
for people to live in apartments i did
not know that i am going to get one of
those things and we'll report on it in a
couple weeks